show and the fbi joining forces in the
search for two people accused in a
violent case out of the south valley
thank you for joining us at four i'm
kirsten joyce and i'm christian casadas
the two agencies working side by side to
find michael overton and christine
schultz investigators say they are
wanted in a murder robbery investigation
we believe the motive is that the
boyfriend had expensive jewelry that was
inside the house a mantune is on for
this couple michael overton and
christine schultz investigators
connecting them to that murder robbery
on march 25 at a home on bright nimbus
avenue near robindale and jones when
units arrived on scene they located a
deceased 24 year old woman suffering
from numerous gunshot wounds the victim
natalie mandalay came face to face with
the armed intruders they got into a
shootout after the gunfire exchange one
of the males named kamari oliver
panicked and fled the residence komari
got into a white mercedes and drove off
and left the others at the scene
according to police mondelez boyfriend
arrived to the home at the same time he
chased the mercedes ramming it with his
car into a brick wall kamari took off on
foot but was arrested days later overton
schultz and another man ran from the
home we do believe there's a very high
chance that they have fled the state
we did have some information that they
had fled to the east coast but we don't
know if that's accurate while
investigators say this was a targeted
robbery they say schultz knew the victim
and orchestrated the crime the third man
has not been identified we would like
the community work with us to bring them
to justice
the fbi is offering a 20 thousand dollar
reward for the capture of the couple now
if you have any information about them
you're asked to please call the number
right there on your screen 1-800 call
fbi